the president came out swinging on
Saturday describing the need for
immigrants to assimilate and learn the
language of the countries that they are
moving to he also explained how there is
legitimate fear among native populations
over the massive influx of newcomers the
only surprising aspect of those
statements is that they were not made by
President Donald Trump they were made by
President Barack Obama that's a far cry
from the open borders policies of the
modern Democrat Party we will examine
what that shift means for the left in
2020 then speaking of 2020 Democrat
congressman and presidential candidate
Eric's wall well tweeted out yesterday I
am you which contradicts my previous
belief that he was he and I and me and
we are the walrus goo goo goo joob
finally the mailbag I'm Eric's wall well
and this is the Eric's wall well show
[Music]
I'm having a real identity crisis this
is so difficult with all of these
Democrats telling me I am they
previously I was Pedro I think I was
bait Oh for a while there's a lot of
identity crisis I'm gonna be speaking
tonight at the University of Missouri
Kansas City on identity crises on how
men are not women we have a lot to get
to but first let's make a little money
honey and let's talk about a very
important message paid for by the
National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration
Mitsu is working hard to combat texting
while driving
cops are writing tickets for people all
over the place well if they text while
they drive you drive you text you pay
thousands of people will die every year
in crashes related to distracted driving
in cops or writing tickets for those who
do it texting and driving isn't just a
dangerous problem it is deadly in fact
thousands of people die every year in
crashes related to distracted driving
that's why cops are out writing tickets
for those who text while they drive and
they're doing it to save lives between
2012 and 2017 nearly 20,000 people died
in crashes involving a distracted driver
and if your own safety isn't enough
reason to stop driving while distracted
here's another one it's also illegal so
remember if you text while driving you
will get caught you drive you text you
pay texting and driving isn't just a
dangerous problem its deadly and if you
drive while distracted you are three
times more likely to crash far too many
people still don't recognize the dangers
do you know that when you send or
receive a text you take your eyes off
the road for about five seconds and at
55 miles per hour that's like driving
more than the length of a football field
with your eyes closed it's why cops are
writing tickets to anyone caught texting
while driving and they're doing it to
save lives
remember if you text while driving you
will get caught you drive your texts you
pay it's very stupid to text while you
drive and how how bad will you feel if
you get into some awful accident that
hurts you or hurts somebody else because
you because you can't wait to say
tee-hee-hee and send an emoji
don't be stupid so these comments that
came out on Saturday from the president
are provoking
shock consternation at the xenophobia
the bigotry the hatefulness the
President of the United States saying
that we should force immigrants to our
countries to assimilate we should
encourage them to assimilate it is
incumbent on them to assimilate to learn
the language
how xenophobic doesn't it sound just
like Donald Trump except it's not Donald
Trump it is Barack Obama here is him
saying it himself if you're gonna have a
coherent cohesive society then everybody
has to have some agreed-upon rules it's
you know it's not racist to say if
you're gonna be here then you should
learn the language of the country that
you just arrived at that's not racist
chips actually Triggs actly
true what he is saying is exactly right
he opens up he says should we want to
encourage newcomers to learn the
language of the country they're moving
to of course it's not racist to say if
you're gonna be here you should learn
the language of the country you arrived
at of course we need to have some sort
of common language in which all of us
can work and learn and understand each
other of course this is simply natural
in a republic such as ours especially in
a republic where you have to govern
yourselves you need to be able to talk
to each other and quite literally you
need to share a language even if you
don't use words in exactly the same way
even if you don't share opinions even if
you don't share a view of the world you
at least need to have the same words and
symbols and and language that will allow
you to communicate and he Barack Obama
makes an even better point he says
reducing fear on the part of people who
are already there requires some levels
of adaptation from the people who are
coming in there's there is a legitimate
fear this isn't natural it's hardwired
into us that when a group of people
that's very different culturally very
different as different practices speaks
a different language when they come in
you're going to have a bit of fear
because it's so unknown you don't know
what they want you they don't know what
you want you don't know how to get along
together you don't know if they're going
to try to destroy your traditions or if
they're going to adopt them themselves
Obama says we are still wired to only be
able to process knowing about
150 people in our brains he's referring
to aspects of evolutionary psychology
the ideas that come out that really we
can only keep a small number of people
and acquaintances in our heads at any
given time and we really can't expand
beyond that and so he points out now
suddenly we're in cities with strangers
we don't know and were asked to trust
them and it goes against some of our
impulses yes
this is alright Barack Obama's sameness
this is not just a Democrat but a very
left-wing Democrat the most left-wing
president we've had certainly since
Woodrow Wilson certainly since FDR I
guess very and in some ways much more
left-wing than they are and he's just
pointing out the obvious so the daily
caller went out they did a man on the
street video and they read Barack
Obama's comments to people and they they
pretended that they were Donald Trump's
comments and they said what do you think
do you think that those comments are
racist immigration from this weekend and
we're just seeing what people think and
you can read it here that's most
definitely erases out of you I don't
know where he's going you just thought
what you going for extremely racist for
him to believe that English is the only
language that we should know I don't
agree with that statement that you have
to learn English in order to come to
this country so you're not in favor of
any kind of assimilation at all no
English isn't even dominant language in
the world I'm against the idea of
forcing people to learn English you're
saying that if you don't learn English
you can't get a job here you think
people should adopt any parts of
American culture not really no I really
no I think people should be free to live
their life whatever they want to live do
you think it should be encouraged um I
think that the resources should be made
available to and accessible to everyone
are you a favor of open borders as well
yes well I mean you should you should
learn the language but you can't learn
it immediately if you don't know it all
right so of all of those people just
that woman at the ng says yeah you
obviously you should learn the language
okay I guess it's kind of hard to learn
it but you should learn it anyway right
of course you should for for two reasons
by the way on the
and because you you should expect to try
to accommodate yourself to the culture
that you're trying to enter nobody asked
you to come nobody's saying you have to
come over here please please come you
wanted to come into this country you
should have the respect to learn the
language and engage in some of their
cultural practices and radition
also if you don't learn the language you
will not have a successful life if you
come to America and you refuse to learn
English or you say no I mean it you're
gonna take the advice of this leftists
and not learn English you're going to
have a terrible life you're not going to
be able to get a good job you're not
going to be able to make strong social
connections to your community you're
it's just awful advice it's that classic
road to hell is paved with good
intentions
the the left wants to say hey you you do
you I don't want to impose my values on
you but the practical effect of that is
that you create a permanent underclass
of people who can work only the most
difficult and low-paying jobs and who
are totally isolated from the community
as a whole now this isn't just a fringe
view this isn't just people on the
street this is the mainstream view of
the Democrat Party don't assimilate
don't learn the language come over open
borders come on over don't pay any
respect not only to traditions but to
laws as recently as what ten years ago
you had leading Democrats guys like
Chuck Schumer who were basically saying
exactly what Donald Trump is saying on
immigration and exactly what Barack
Obama is now saying on immigration
here's here's just a cut up of Chuck
Schumer and Donald Trump you can barely
tell the difference the American people
want their government to be serious
about protecting the public enforcing
the rule of law and creating a rational
system of legal immigration that will
proactively fit our needs rather than
reactively responding to future waves of
illegal immigration well we want an
immigration policy that's fair equitable
but that's going to protect our people
what the American people are pleading
for is sanity and common sense in our
immigration system so that's it now now
by the way Barack Obama
and Chuck Schumer and all those guys
were quite radical in practice on
immigration in practice they were
encouraging open borders Barack Obama
gave a recklessly unconstitutional
executive amnesty to illegal aliens in
the country however in their rhetoric
they were not that radical in their
rhetoric they were sort of normal and
this gets to this line from Roche
Foucault who famously said hypocrisy is
the tribute vice pays to virtue so they
might have taken these vicious actions
they might have had open borders and
been encouraging people to come in and
not to assimilate but at least in their
language at least in their rhetoric they
were paying tribute to the virtue of
assimilation of enforcing the law of
making people wait in line not letting
certain people cut the line just because
they're from a country closer by than
say a would-be American immigrant from
Ghana or Nigeria or Southeast Asia so in
the mainstream now we've we've gotten
rid of even paying tribute to virtue
Nancy Pelosi is saying that physical
borders to protect our national
sovereignty are immoral and ineffective
of course that never made any sense it
could only be one or the other if it's
ineffective it's not immoral if it's
immoral it's not ineffective but to say
that it is immoral is to now say we have
no right to an immigration regime we
have no right to expect anything from
immigrants who would come to this
country we have no right to expect not
not just that they would learn the
language not just that they would
assimilate and take on cultural
practices we don't even have the right
to expect that they would come into our
country legally we don't even have the
right to expect that they would in their
first action in the country respect a
fundamental law how do we know this for
a fact
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes when she was
not even a congresswoman yet when she
was running she endorsed the policy of
abolishing ice abolishing immigration
and customs enforcement a radical policy
and what happened did the Democrats
laugh at her and push her away no they
all endorsed her policy they you know oh
or Kamala Harris kirsten gillibrand Liz
Warren these are people who are now
running for president they all followed
suit they all endorsed abolishing ice
now then some of them backed off of it
Kamala Harris is trying to pretend now
that she didn't endorse it she totally
did all of those guys did we're talking
about Senate Democrats were talking
about presidential candidates a bunch of
congressmen followed suit the far left
wing Democrat mayor of New York Bill
DeBlasio followed suit
he said Isis time has come and gone we
can't have enforcement of our
immigration laws now Kirsten Gillibrand
Kirsten Gillibrand doesn't show us very
much because she's a completely mediocre
candidate who is probably going to be
out of the Democrat presidential race
before the first debate but she's an
interesting case study because she had
positioned herself for her whole career
as a moderate as a middle-of-the-road or
centrist we can all work together she
was trying to position herself like
Hillary was in the 2000s and she was
kind of the next Hillary Clinton now she
is not only taking a leftward radical
turn she's actually apologizing for all
of her old positions here she is at a
town hall saying please forgive me for
formerly saying that illegal immigration
is a bad thing so I think part of what
Parker's talking about obviously is that
the dramatic change in your position on
this issue over time right from English
obviously as a as a language official
language of the country not supporting
things like benefits for illegal
immigrants that's part of your record as
well what made you change well when I
was a member of Congress from upstate
New York I was really focused on the
priorities of my district when I became
senator of the entire state I recognize
that some of my views really did need to
change they were not thoughtful enough
and didn't care enough about people
outside of the original upstate New York
district that I represented and so I
learned and I think for people who
aspire to be President I think it's
really important that you're able to
admit when you're wrong and that you're
able to grow and learn and listen and be
better and be stronger this is actually
a pretty good answer from her it's a bad
as good an answer as she can give she's
saying when I held those views
I had local interests that I was
representing in the Congress but then I
became a senator and I had broader
interests okay now the problem with this
distinction here the problem with this
excuse is that when even when you're
elected to Congress you're not just
being elected to represent some petty
tiny interest
you're being represent you're being
elected for your judgment for your
judgment to represent a local interest
and the national interest that's why
you're in the federal government but she
actually corrects this a little bit too
and I think you're gonna be hearing a
lot of Democrats giving this same answer
but first let's make a little money
honey with purple mattress you know I'm
on the road you can see I'm in a hotel
room right now
my back hurts my back hurts very much
why does my back hurt because last night
I didn't get to sleep on my purple
matricide to sleep on some stupid hotel
mattress I love my purple mattress I've
had back pain for most of my life and if
the purple mattress really really helps
it is this amazing technology it is not
an innerspring it is not like a memory
foam is this proprietary space-age crazy
technology was literally developed by a
rocket scientist I don't really know how
to describe it you just have to try it
out because it's both firm and soft at
the same time how is that possible I
don't I can't tell you i Ju have to
experience it to believe it
it is amazing I was super skeptical of
this thing going in I didn't want to get
rid of my old mattress then I tried it
out one night one night I got rid of
them old mattress quickly as I possibly
could it / I can't say enough about
purple you have to go try it you get a
hundred night risk free trial if you're
not fully satisfied you can return your
mattress for a full refund back by 10
year warranty free shipping and returns
returns free old mattress removal free
setup you're gonna love it right now my
listeners get a free purple pillow with
the purchase of a mattress and these
pillows are fabulous too
the only way to get this purple pillow
right now is to Tex Knowles que no wles
2 8 4 8 8 8
that's an addition to all the great free
gifts they offer site-wide only way to
get the pillow Knolls - eight four eight
eight eight text KO wles 2 8 4 8 8 8
message and data rates may apply
so kirsten gillibrand this is her excuse
she says well I represented a local
interest and then I represented a bigger
interest and I changed my
use that doesn't quite explain because
basically what she's admitting is I had
poor judgment and I was Petty and
selfish and then I became I don't know
still petty and selfish but my
circumstance has changed not a great
answer
so she actually does go further and she
says yeah I realized I was wrong I was
wrong
she says she was wrong to encourage
immigrants to learn English to encourage
immigrants to assimilate to oppose
illegal immigration that she was wrong
I'm sorry Mia culpa Mia culpa mea Maxima
culpa that's what she's saying
how pathetic but this is the way that
the whole race is going to go when you
look at these candidates who are like
wind not windmills one of my old weather
vanes when you look at the weather vane
candidates like Kamala Harris is one of
them Kirsten Gillibrand is very much one
of them bado is one of them a lot of
weather vane candidates out there the
ones who say make me into whatever
candidate you want shape me however you
want to shape me Eric's wall well I am
you Eric's wall well for those weather
vane candidates they're telling us which
way the party is going and it is very
clear the wind is all blowing in the
direction of open borders and illegal
immigration and this creates a big
problem for Democrats in 2020 Americans
hate illegal immigration by the way
Americans hate large-scale legal
immigration - there was a study that
came out from Harvard Harris at the end
of last year it showed that the majority
of Americans want to radically reduce
even the number of legal immigrants
coming into this country they want to
reduce it by over 50% upwards of 60%
down to about half a million per year
where were it about 1.2 million per year
right now
so it shows you this isn't just about
illegal immigration this isn't just
about people violating our laws at the
border there actually are broader
questions here of assimilation learning
the language integrating people into
society so that you don't have permanent
underclasses so do you don't have people
isolating themselves Barack Obama gets
this Barack Obama's talking about that
that's why he's not just speaking about
illegal immigration sometimes
Trump he only wants to talk about
illegal immigration and he says I'm so
pro immigration I want more people
coming here legally than ever it's kind
of missing the point the point is not
just this narrow question of illegal
immigration poll after poll shows that
immigration broadly not just illegal
aliens is the number one issue for
Americans and this creates a big problem
for Democrats in 2020 because they've
gone so radical on it
if Barack Obama ran today with his
current stated views on immigration he
would not win the Democrat nomination he
could not say what he said on Saturday
at his town hall in Berlin and win the
Democrat nomination this year it would
not happen why have the Democrats gone
so radical on this they've gone so
radical because they are reflexively
opposing Trump which is a bad idea in
some ways it's a good idea because
Donald Trump is personally unlikable to
a lot of people a lot of people find him
personally offensive but his policies
are very very popular I know you can
find some polo know that really people
hate x y&z provision of the wall or x
y&z BS they hate the tax law fine
whatever
what that is reflecting is people's
aversion to Donald Trump's personality
people like his policies which is why
these issues immigration illegal aliens
the economy taxation that's why they
always rank at the top of people's
concerns Donald Trump knew that he knew
that when he was running for office he's
a he's a very smart politician in many
ways and so he picks these very popular
stands of very popular issues and
stances that only he is taking that
actually opposed the kind of broad
political consensus and he wins on those
issues not on his personality on his
issues and Democrats stupidly say well
we're gonna reflexively oppose Trump
because he's personally unlikable and so
by opposing him we're going to oppose
all of his issues which does what it
backs you into this awful corner where
now they've got to defend
illegal immigration they've got to
defend not learning English they've got
to defend not assimilating they've got
to defend open borders how are they
going to be able to defend all of that
who is going to vote for them they're
gonna win some plaudits from pundits and
hardline activists but if Barack Obama
today is too conservative to win the
Democrat nomination
Brock Obama then who is gonna win it
who's going to get that nomination and
who do they think is gonna vote for that
person to be President of the United
States what voters in Wyoming and
Pennsylvanian Michigan Florida who do
they think are gonna vote for those
people it's it's a I I think the reason
Barack Obama's making these comments is
he's trying to open the door for
Democrats to moderate on this issue
because he's looking down the path and
he's saying this is electoral suicide
for them the question is or Democrats
gonna heed his warning or is Barack
Obama old news and they're moving on
they're moving on to some new candidate
who are they moving on to they're moving
on to Eric's wall well and and this is
sort of just by definition Eric's wall
well is a Democrat congressman who is a
nobody but he's decided he's running for
president this year because everybody's
running for president this year and
Eric's wall well really is the answer I
think to this conundrum for Democrats
because Eric's wall well tweeted out
yesterday he said I am running for
president of the United States I see you
I hear you I'm for you I am you he's me
okay but this does solve a problem for
Democrats because right now none of
their candidates are going to be elected
president there's no chance and so if
they keep running on this radical
platform so let's say Donald Trump gets
reelected everybody votes for Donald
Trump if Eric's whoa well is all of us
and one of us is Donald Trump then that
means that
Donald Trump is Eric's wall well which
means no matter who wins the election
Eric's wall well becomes president
Touche Eric very very well done
now the slogan itself pretty bad pretty
stupid slogan actually the most tedious
and cliche slogan probably in all of
politics because it's so on the nose
I've been saying this now four days I've
been saying this since he announced he
was running Eric's wall well is not a
presidential candidate he's a parody of
a presidential candidate if there were a
presidential candidate on The Simpsons
if there were a presidential candidate
on South Park it would be Eric's wall
well he's he's taking this fact of
campaigning which is that you need to
show that you empathize with people and
he's just putting it so on the nose he's
saying I am you I am you see I empathize
it's not believable if you have to say
it it's like so many things if you have
to say it it's probably not true the
most famous version of this stupid
slogan I'm you comes from one of the
most hilariously awful campaigns in
modern political history this was from
the Tea Party wave I believe it was 2010
Christine O'Donnell was running for the
Senate there was an accusation out
somewhere that she's a witch and she
decided first of all she decided to
answer this accusation which was
probably not advisable but then she
decided to answer it with this same
awkward awful slogan I'm you I'm not a
witch
I'm nothing you've heard I'm you none of
us are perfect but none of us can be
happy with what we see all around us
politicians who think spending trading
favors and backroom deals are the ways
to stay in office I'll go to Washington
and do what you do I'm Christine
O'Donnell and I approve this message
I'm you I'm you and you're a witch if
you're gonna cast spells on everybody
so awkward so now Eric's wall well has
two campaign slogans he has I am you and
the other one that he has he put it in
this video and it's on his materials do
good I am you do good because the
writers of The Simpsons are the top
campaign advisers to Eric's wall well I
guess a parody of a presidential
campaign Norm Macdonald the greatest
living comedian had a great tweet on
this both tweeted out he said I'm
running for president I'm you and norm
responds he says this is fine news
indeed it explains my self-loathing bad
bad start for for Eric's wall well a
really bad start actually because we dig
here Stan Gillibrand she's a total
mediocrity she'll probably be out she's
starting out way better than Eric's wall
well Joe Biden's starting out a little
bit better bado a little bit better you
don't want to start out as a joke and
he's starting out as a joke he can't
afford to do that especially as an
unknown candidate at least if you're a
superstar candidate like Joe Biden you
can afford a little bit of being a joke
you can't do that when you're nobody the
only impression people have of small
well now is that he's a joke at least
Kirsten Gillibrand is lying low enough
to maybe be considered for I don't know
VP or some position and some Democrat
administration she's kind of a nonentity
sois well is a punch line hard to
imagine where he goes from here where
will we go from here we have a lot more
to get to we have got to get to the mail
but first let's say goodbye to Facebook
in YouTube you got to go to daily
wire.com daily wire.com 10 bucks a month
100 dollars for an annual membership you
get me you get the and reclaim ensure
you get the Ben Shapiro sure you get the
Matt Walsh oh you get to ask questions
in the mailbag coming right up you get
to ask questions on the backstage show
you get another Kingdom and you get
something much better than this
totally faceless white coffee cup that I
have in this hotel room you get the
leftist cheers tumbler the leftist years
tumblr is very important because now
it's actually doubly important
previously the leftist here's tumblr was
a great vessel for leftist tears nice
and salty and delicious and you drink
them but now that Eric's wall well who
is a leftist is you then I guess that
means the leftist here's tumblr is a
vessel for all of our tears you've just
gotten it's a twofer you've doubled your
usage of the leftist tears tumblr you
can't afford not to get it go to daily
wire calm we will be right back with the
mailbag
all right we have got much more to get
to but first let's make a little money
honey with an important message for your
safety I am talking of course about the
what who is who is sponsoring this ad
paid for by the National Highway Traffic
Safety Administration Nitsa is working
hard to combat texting while driving
cops are writing tickets for people who
are texting while driving you drive you
text you pay simple as that
thousands of people die every year in
crashes related to distracted driving
and cops are now writing tickets for
people who text while they drive texting
and driving is not just a dangerous
problem it is a deadly problem in fact
thousands of people die every year in
these crashes related to distracted
driving so the cops are out writing
tickets to those who text while driving
they're going doing they're doing it
rather to save lives between 2012 and
2017 nearly 20,000 people died in
crashes involving a distracted driver if
your own safety isn't enough reason to
stop tech driving while distracted
here's another one it is illegal if you
text while driving you will get caught
you drive you text you pay texting and
driving isn't just a dangerous problem
it is a deadly problem you are three
times more likely to crash
if you drive while distracted that is
why the cops are writing tickets to
anyone call it texting while driving
they're doing it to save lives when you
send a receive a text you take your eyes
off the road for about five seconds at
55 miles an hour that's more than the
length of a football field that you're
driving with your eyes closed if you
text while driving you will get caught
you drive you text you pay alright let's
get let's get to the mailbag so we've
got so much more to get to but we're
just gonna have to wait maybe I'll talk
about it tonight in my speech I'm gonna
be speaking at the University of
Missouri Kansas City if you are in
Kansas City come on by the doors are
going to open at 7:30 Central Time
we're gonna try to stream that out the
speech will start at eight o'clock
central so what is that 6:00 p.m.
pacific 9 p.m. Eastern the topic of
discussion tonight is men
are not women this should not be a crazy
topic but apparently it's the most
controversial thing in the world so come
check it out on to the mailbag from
garland question two questions first
what would your ideal humanities
department look like in a university
second do you know of any good studies
regarding bias in academia thanks a lot
yeah I know of a bet a million studies
regarding bias in academia the most
important study is just open your own
eyes and you can see it pretty clearly
my ideal humanities department for the
first question would focus on the core
liberal arts things like the classics
things like history things like
literature it would not focus on silly
non academic fields pseudo academic
fields ideological fields like lesbian
dance studies
I don't know women's gender studies race
and migrations Studies all of those
studies things I would basically get rid
of and I would go back to core aspects
of the humanities languages art
literature history though those are the
things that are really going to form the
basis of your education and this is
important for conservatives - it's not
it's not just that we get to spend all
our time on our own ideological reading
we we should also go back to those
classics and that is going to form the
best education you can get as well as
far as these studies go just a few of
them
there was a poll came out sixty-one
percent of all Americans have a negative
view of higher education so that means
it's not just conservatives it's not
just Republicans it's a majority of all
Americans there was an Oxford study in
2018 that identified significant what
they called scholar activism in fields
such as sociology and Poli Sci highly
politicized fields there was a study
from Brooklyn College and George Mason
University found that at colleges
liberal professors outnumber
conservative professors 12 to one it
gets worse in certain departments like
history very important departments that
that number rises to 33 to 133 liberal
professors for every one conservative
professor the National Association of
scholars found nearly
percent of top-ranked liberal arts
colleges have how many Republican
professors give you guess zero zero
forty percent of the top-ranked schools
another study of sociology professors
found just two percent identifies
conservative when you add in
libertarians it gets up to four percent
eighty three percent say they are
liberal or radical and there was a study
from Queen's University of Charlotte
it found that conservative students
self-censor during class discussions
they pair it what their liberal
professors say this was backed up I
think there was another study by the
foundation for individual rights in
education said exactly the same thing a
lot of studies to show this it's it's
not a conspiracy I think everybody knows
that I think the majority of Americans
know it and so how do you fix that it's
not that you're all of a sudden going to
get super conservative professors you
should just stop the liberal
indoctrination you should stop those
ideological majors and ideological
pseudo departments and get back to the
classics at least then that's one way to
rein it in from James hi Michael do you
have a favorite passage or phrase from
the Bible thanks James yes I do
leviticus 17 7 you shall no longer
worship the goat demons after whom you
[ __ ] this will be a statute for all
times also translated as you shall no
longer sacrifice your sacrifices to goat
demons after whom you [ __ ] there's just
something about that the language is
very evocative in where is it an exodus
thou shalt not suffer a witch to live
that's a good one or is that Deuteronomy
I don't know there are many many good
passages of the Bible but broadly
speaking you should read the Bible as a
whole I'm actually quite I caution one
against pulling out just one part of the
Bible and saying ah yes this this is the
be-all and end-all you know in the
parable of the prodigal son that that
parable has been described as the gospel
within the gospel john 3:16 for god
so loved the world that He gave His only
begotten Son that whosoever believes in
Him might not perish but might have
everlasting life that's been described
as the gospel within the gospel there
are important passages but really you've
got to take it all together I what a lot
of shallow thinking atheists do when
they try to debunk the Bible is they say
ah but how do you defend this line you
defend it in the light of all of
Revelation in the light of all scripture
and in the light of sacred tradition and
in the light of natural law and in the
light of philosophy and so if we don't
if we don't take that whole view we're
likely to take ourselves down shallow
paths from logan dear Michael I've got
an audio book credit for my audible
accounting a good American history
recommendation or a recommendation on
history that leads up to the American
Revolution something along the lines of
the great Christopher Columbus or early
colonization thank you God bless Logan
yes I have two books both of which will
be good inaudible if you want Columbus
you should read Admiral of the ocean sea
by Samuel Eliot Morrison one of the
greatest American Historians ever and a
fabulous very long but fabulous
biography of Columbus and if you're
interested in colonization say from the
time of the Mayflower and early the
early more United States American
experiment you can you should read
Nathaniel Philbrick book Mayflower
fabulous book really good about the
voyage on the Mayflower in the early
Plymouth Colony Isle and it's very
readable both of those are very readable
book so highly recommended for both of
those while you're driving or working
out or whatever from Sara
hello Michael I go to a lot of baseball
games I often wear a baseball hat with
my long hair tied up in the back is it
rude not to take my hat off during the
anthem or is it different for girls love
listening to you and Clavin Thank You
Sara I'm sorry to tell you this you
asked the question on etiquette so I'll
give you the answer you have to take
your baseball cap off the rules are
different for women and girls women are
generally speaking permitted to wear
hats indoors or in houses of worship or
even when the national anthem is playing
or the flag is being paraded by
except when it's a baseball cap except
when it is a unisex cap in that case you
are expected to take the head off when
the flag passes by in a parade or when
the anthem is playing I don't make the
rules I just enforce them take it up
with Emily Post from Joel dapper
debonair of The Daily wire I come to you
with a fashion question another fashion
question that plagues me whenever a
special occasion is upon me what is the
point of wearing a tie they just seem to
be upside-down nooses that always want
to choke your neck I never have to dress
formally for my occupation and when a
special event arrives that warrants me
wearing one I always have to look up how
to tie a tie on my search engine should
this pointless piece of fabric die like
powdered wigs no learn how to tie a tie
act like a man
what's the matter with you ties are very
important where do ties come from ties I
have a pretty interesting history
actually ties come from Croat migrants
why I know this I don't know when Croat
migrants came during the Manichaean
persecution of 1700 or so years 1800
years ago something like that I guess
1700 years ago they come over into I
guess what you would call Croatia and
they they wore to identify themselves
handkerchiefs around their necks so they
called themselves crow hats they called
themselves kora vets and this phrase
evolved into profit that's the in
Italian Traviata is what you say for tie
you wear a cravat it's a certain type of
tie when did this become popular in the
West it became popular during the 30
Years War when Croat mercenaries were
used and the the young boy king louis
xiv took a liking to style trend the
cravat and he started wearing one and
then like everything moved the 14th did
it became very popular ties tie
everything together I don't wear one
nearly as much as I should highly
recommend wearing a tie the problem in
our society is not that we're too casual
that is definitely not the problem the
problem in our society is were were or
I'm sorry the problem is that we're too
casual the problem is not that we're too
formal we are too
we're too casual in our speech were too
casual in our conversation we're too
casual in our dress or too casual in our
dancing in our singing in our attire tie
it all together act like a man be
civilized we're a tie from Norman hi
Michael according to his latest book Ben
seems to think that the very essence of
paganism is polytheism thus for him the
Greek philosopher his discovery of a
single unmoved mover and cosmic Telos
were an escape from the pagan worldview
Dante however famously kept the pagan
philosophers out of paradise because
regardless of their heady intellectual
knowledge they still needed conversion
through Christ who is Right who is ripe
Ben or Dante Dante buddy and if Dante
what is it that philosophical pagans
still lack that makes them not fully
converted to a judeo-christian worldview
thanks norm okay a lot here in this
question but it's a very very good
question so what Ben is saying in his
book is paganism is polytheism and then
the Greeks like Plato discover Aristotle
think think of the unmoved mover the
cosmic Tilos this this idea of a single
God and this escapes them from the pagan
worldview except Dante doesn't put them
in Paradise he puts them in hell this is
sort of true he actually puts the the
Greek philosophers the virtuous pagans
broadly speaking which included Saladin
a Muslim it included some Romans he puts
them in the first circle of hell but
it's really just sort of fine it's sort
of nice it's called the Elysian Fields
and he puts them there not to punish
them for their transgressions he puts
them there because they don't have hope
they are pagans they don't have hope of
the resurrection they don't have the
hope of Christianity and actually you
use the phrase judeo-christian worldview
here that's a very apt phrase because
Dante doesn't put the Jews in hell
why doesn't Dante put the Jews in hell
he doesn't put the Jews in hell because
the Jews are a messianic people they are
awaiting the coming of the Messiah they
hope but the pagans and the Romans by
definition do not have hope so even if
they can recognize the unmoved mover the
cosmic Tilos whatever they recognize
these important intellectual aspects of
God they lack a a living faith they lack
hope and so through their own ideas they
preclude themselves from paradise
that's the difference there and
fortunately those who have a messianic
religion do have hope from Scott
hello Michael my two questions for you
first you think the left wants to be
like the book 1984 an animal forum with
how they are controlling the government
and media second do you think the left
wants to bring segregation back with
intersectionality thank you and keep
doing great work big fan of you and The
Daily wire yes yes yes is that is that
clear enough okay we want to do all of
those things yeah they do of course they
do they want to what do you mean they're
do they want to bring 1984 an animal
form do they want to have a centralised
power associated with the government
that controls you yes
not just controls you as a mechanism of
politics but controls you even in your
thought that but controls you even in
your culture but controls but you can
say what controls your personal behavior
controls your personal opinions yes
they're openly advocating for that
they're openly advocating for that now
do they want to bring segregation back
with intersectionality yes I mean they
are literally doing it they are
literally segregating campuses and
giving black students black only dorm
rooms black only study areas that is
obviously what they're doing then they
might say we're doing it for the best of
intentions okay maybe you are the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
I'm sure people had good intentions when
they were segregating the country 50
years ago sure people had good
intentions when they were advocating for
totalitarian systems sure we judge we
judge others on their actions we judge
ourselves on our intentions the
- hell is paved with good intentions
alright I gotta go finish writing my
speech come on out tonight it's gonna be
a lot of fun at University of Missouri
Kansas City we will analyze the most
controversial deep difficult question of
our age are men women come check it out
then in the meantime I'm Eric's wall
well this is the Eric's wall will show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
Audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey guys
overall the Matt Walsh show today Pope
Benedict has emerged from seclusion to
discuss the sex abuse crisis and he has
some insights that are true but also
pretty startling and we'll talk about
that also according to a recent report
Google has a running blacklist and
you'll never guess who's on it we'll
discuss also we'll talk about black
holes and The Lion King and biblical end
times prophecies there's a lot to cover
on the show today so come over and check
it out